HAPPEN TO ANOTHER PRESIDENT
AGAIN EVER, EVER, EVER.
BEFORE JOINING US NOW, AUTHOR OF
THE NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER "THE
RUSSIAN HOAX: THE ILLICIT SCHEME
TO CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON AND
FRAME DONALD TRUMP."
GET   MATT GAETZ.
WHAT ARE YOU -- WHAT DO YOU KNOW
IS HAPPENING?
>> I BELIEVE WE ARE DAZED IF NOT
WEEKS ALWAYS FOR THE MOST IN
COMPELLING EVIDENCE IN THE
BIGGEST POLITICAL SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
"HANNITY" VIEWERS HAVE KNOWN
THAT IT WAS THE DOSSIER FUNDED
BY DEMOCRATS THAT FUELED THIS
INVESTIGATION.
COMEY AND BRENNAN AND CLAPPER,
THEY DIDN'T DEFEND THE DOSSIER
BECAUSE IT WAS WRITTEN BY A
KNOWN LIAR AS HE POINTED OUT IN
HONG KONG.
SASEBO, CHINA SAID THEY HAD ALL
THESE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS ABOUT
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
IT HAS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
FIGHT SOURCE THAT PAPADOPOULOS
MIGHT'VE BEEN TALKING TO
RUSSIANS.
THERE WAS WESTERN INTELLIGENCE
SET TO SPY ON PAPADOPOULOS AND
THERE'S A RECORDING AND
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CONVERSATION.
PAPADOPOULOS DENIES ANY ILLEGAL
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
THEY HAD EVIDENCE PRESUMABLY
THAT WAS AGAINST PAPADOPOULOS
AND FOR HIM.
WHAT THEY WILL EVER BE ABLE TO
DEFEND IS THAT THEY NEVER
PRESENTED THAT EVIDENCE TO THE
FISA COURT.
>> Sean: THEY WERE WARNED BY
BRUCE OHR, AUGUST 2016.
THEY WERE WARNED BY THIS WOMAN
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT TEN DAYS
PRIOR TO THE SIGNING OF THE
FIRST FISA APPLICATION.
NOW WE KNOW ON THIS WHOLE NEW
LEVEL YOU'RE DESCRIBING, THOUGH
THEY ARE WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION FROM THE FISA COURT
DESPITE ON AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CAMPAIGN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS WHAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR MEANS WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
THEM PUTTING THEIR THUMB ON THE
SCALE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS NO OBLIGATION
BEFORE A SECRET COURT WITH NO
DEFENSE ATTORNEY TO PRESENT ALL
OF THE EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE THAT
THEY ARE PROVIDED, ALL OF THE
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
HERE THEY ONLY PRESENT EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD CAST PEOPLE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN A BAD LIGHT WITHOUT
THEIR MULTIPLE PROFESSIONS OF
INNOCENCE.
COMEY AND CLAPPER AND BRENNAN
ARE ALL GOING TO SAY
PAPADOPOULOS MIGHT'VE KNOWN HE
WAS BEING SURVEILLED WHEN HE
SAID NONE OF THIS STUFF WAS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
BUT THERE IS STILL NO EXCUSE FOR
WHY THEY DIDN'T GO BEFORE COURT
AND I'M SURE GREGG JARRETT CAN
EXPLAIN ALL THE LAWS AND RULES
THEY BROKE.
>> Sean: I HAVE A FRIEND OF
MINE IN THE STUDIO AND THAT'S
WHAT I WAS TALKING TO.
GO AHEAD.
>> CONGRESSMAN GATES IS CORRECT.
THERE IS AN EXTRA DUTY THAT THE
FBI, JAMES COMEY, AND SALLY
YATES AT THE DOJ HAD WHEN THEY
PRESENTED THEIR WARRANT
APPLICATION TO SPY ON SOMEBODY.
IF THEY HAVE EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE
THAT, NOT ONLY THAT, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, ALL THE INFORMATION
HAS TO BE VERIFIED.
IF THEY DISCOVER LATER ON THAT
IT'S NOT VERIFIED OR THEY WERE
WRONG, THEY HAVE TO IMMEDIATELY
NOTIFY THE COURT THAT WE GOT IT
WRONG.
WE MUST NOW RECONSIDER.
THEY DIDN'T DO ANY OF THAT.
THAT IS A FRAUD ON THE COURT.
>> Sean: IT'S A PREMEDITATED
FRAUD.
LYING BY OMISSION, NOT
HIGHLIGHTING PAID FOR IT.
NOT VERIFIED.
THEY WERE WARNED TWICE, MAYBE
THREE TIMES.
THEY WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST LEVEL TO
IMPACT THE ELECTION AND THE
OUTCOME, ALSO THE PERSON THEY
SAVED FROM CLEAR INDICTMENT.
NUMBER TWO, THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY USED IT TO
TRY AND TAKE DOWN A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
>> IT IS RANKED CORRUPTION.
IT'S USING YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICE TO TARGET SOMEBODY FOR
POLITICAL REASONS, AND LYING TO
A COURT IN THE PROCESS.
ITS ABUSE OF POWER.
IT'S PERJURY.
IT'S A FALSE STATEMENT.
IT'S OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> Sean: LET ME THROW IT TO
MATT.
>> IT'S EASY TO INVENT ALIVE.
IT'S EVEN EASIER TO SPREAD A LIE
IF THERE IS NOBODY THERE TO
CHALLENGE IT AND THIS IS THE
HEARING IN FRONT OF THE FISA
COURT.
NOBODY ON THE OTHER SIDE TO LOOK
OUT FOR CARTER PAGE.
>> Sean: EITHER COMEY LIED
WHEN HE SAID SHE TOLD ME TO CALL
IT A MATTER, OR THE RIGHT A
LYNCH LINE.
ONE OF THEM LIED UNDER OATH.
WHICH ONE?
>> MULTIPLE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
COMEY WAS LYING AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS WHY COMEY IS ATTACKING
OUR GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR.
BILL BARR IS ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS WE WILL GET DOWN TO
WHO COMMITTED THESE CRIMES.
>> Sean: I'VE GOT TO RUN.
>> IT ROOTS BACK IN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.